[Musique]
la la la la
dibi dibi tout était de te la beetle
c'est bon 88% des français ont déjà été
sur des sites extraconjugaux et vous non
jamais parce que c'est à l'âme c'est ça
pardon pardon je ne comprends pas quand
vous ne parlez pas le suédois non ah ok
cours vous avez comment pascal moi c'est
jude law chanter 88% des français ont
déjà été sur des sites extra conjugaux
et vous non non jamais ça vous est
jamais arrivé d'aller sur un an cet
extra conjugales non vous allez
directement sur terrain ou au bois de
boulogne non plus non non c'est d'accord
ok vous n'avez jamais été infidèle dans
votre vie il dira la caméra n'y a pas de
soucis vraiment difficile mais parce
qu'on les sent l'équipe les voilà quoi
88% des français ont déjà été sur des
sites extra conjugaux et vous non non
non j'ai prêté arrêtez vos conneries
s'il vous plaît s'il vous plaît à jouer
devant la caméra
je suis suisse moi je suis pour la
liberté totale c'est pour la liberté
totale
jamais trompé toi non j'ai contraire à
ma religion aucune musulmans là tu es
musulman ok d'accord on peut pas trop le
dire à la télé parce que les muslim pas
trop à la mode en ce moment ça va
revenir à la mode comme les converses
chance alors imagine a peut-être comment
tu réagis pas imaginer par exemple il y
avait deux femmes à l'arrivée vous fait
mal je suis désolé mais j'ai trouvé un
autre pas qui plus beau que toi il
s'appelle cyril hanouna
excuse moi je vais aller manger je
reviens tout de suite j'ai un peu faim
je reviens je vous fais à lui et là
dessus je fais c'est comme ça vous
travaillez c'est pas normal ça s'il doit
manger ça deux minutes chaque 3e à 2 min
3 minutes vous n'allez pas travailler et
compliquée j'en avoue pas et vous
sérieux voire moi j'ai jamais été sur
n'importe quel site personne n'avoue
seulement versailles